all right so I spent my first twenty six
months in the Maricopa County Jail
system run by Sheriff Joe Arpaio and
then when I was sentenced I got moved
over to the Arizona Department of
Corrections where I served three for
three something years my total sentence
was 5 and 3/4 years almost 6 so the
characters I met t-bone I can't remember
what we talked about t-bone we haven't
talked about t-bone yet now okay good
- Tony's Zeena Frankie all the main
characters have started writing about my
blog John Steele Journal Frankie I
didn't meet in the jail but most of them
were met in the Arizona Department of
Corrections yes
that now the jail housed about 10,000
prisoners and I was in about three
different security levels there and the
Arizona Department prisoners back then
they got prisons all over the state so I
was in various prison started out the
Supermax because of games the
prosecutors pain and then ended up in a
federal deportation prison which you
have to go through if you're gonna get
sent back to England okay yeah I mean
that is some of the most brutal [ __ ]
I've ever heard like brutal prison
stories violent prison stories I've ever
heard I've never heard of anyone being
decapitated in the prison or let alone
castrating themselves in a prison cell
like that seems like the most grotesque
violent [ __ ] I've ever heard happen in a
prison yeah I wasn't there when the
eyeball extractions occurred that was
way before I've been arrested but it was
a period of time in Arizona prison
history where 60 minutes did the
documentary and said that Florence
prison was the most dangerous square
mile of real estate in the entire United
States and I that's just one of many
stories yeah that I heard about it back
then whereby you know it's just the big
bad redneck cops and all the rapings
going on and mm-hmm
another dead president nobody cuz and
where where were you when Xena performed
this
castration were you in that prison at
the time or was this a story she told
you no no I was oh and she didn't tell
me all the prisoners started to write to
me
oh this was after you had already gotten
out yeah yeah all the prisoners were
writing to me my friends and they were
like you know wow she's got balls and
she's [ __ ] hardcore than any of us no
one would do that you know this to do
that take such a strong mind it's truly
amazing that she even survived that I
mean I'm sure she was pretty close to
death when all right I met I won't see
any names and the one that Xena did it
after this one did it I wasn't around
when the one did it but I know what
happened because all the prisoners told
me and what happened was this one
successfully cut off both balls and then
she cauterized the wound with a
cigarette lighter mm-hmm okay and it got
infected so she was carried out on a
stretcher it got infected and she was
busted it's you know it's it's a
disciplinary matter then you violated
the prison laws so she got in all kinds
of trouble for doing what she did yeah
but she looked like a woman honestly
guys would compete in to try and get her
you know in bet and she was totally
about it right
Oh is she not about it she had a tough
guy he was protecting her but then she
got moved off the yard so I think things
got so chaotic for her okay yeah yeah
that's gonna be a weird dynamic
especially for the people running the
prison when one of the prisoners and
Sarge to it like when they're on that
line of being trans and like oh they
love they enjoy sex with the other men
that's got to be a weird line to dance
when you're in charge of that prison
right I mean they just let it go is that
it's not a common thing all right rape
is so common in prison you have to go
through a rape class to get
let's get raped which is a complete
waste of time
the attitude of the authorities is we've
shown in the class that's Hicks our box
so what if they're raping each other
yeah in this rape class you watch a
video and there are some predators in
the dayroom
and it shows the young prisoners coming
in now if the Predators are able to coax
the young people who are hungry into
taking food candy Snickers bars whatever
yeah then they're in debt so then they
say look you got to pay this debt off or
else we're going to stab you well I've
got no money
all right well go in that cell over
there
do whatever he says and your debt will
be cleared or else we're going to stab
you and kill you so if you're a scared
young person going in
you just got tricked into taking food
and getting into debt what are you going
to do to get all that situation you're
gonna have to fight your way out of it
or you know some of them the mauville
the ones just break down and do it and
then that's it once they've been
converted into a prison Punk it's called
getting turned out becoming a prison
Punk
they are then prostituted out for the
rest of those thing and the attitude of
the prisoners is if you don't man up you
deserve it because there's a hierarchy
and the bottom are the snitches the
punks Trane's you know that's why Xena
had a very tough boyfriend yeah these
people get brutalized show them on sex
offenders snitches punks these are all
at the bottom of the spectrum so now the
conclusion of the rape class was to stop
rape you have to report it if you've put
anything you snitch so after we went to
this rape class a young mentally ill
prisoner was gang-raped on the yard I
was there and nobody reported a single
thing right yeah they reckon more men
are getting raped in prison than the
rapes for females every world in the
free world yeah
now how long did it take you from the
time you were first went in cuz you know
obviously there was kind of like a
self-discovery you had to go through for
a while right like you talked about it
I've heard you talk about it before it's
like self reflection like looking at
yourself in a mirror for a long period
of time until you can finally figure out
how to channel this situation that
you're in into something that's gonna
put you on some sort of trajectory
forward right like you have to your
mindset had to go through a change at
one point was there a point that you can
remember that you kind of like redefined
your outlook on where you were yeah I
was wild when I got arrested you know
I'd quit running the criminal enterprise
but I was still going out on the
weekends of all my party friends you
know I answer Isis I'm a business
graduate that had gangster writers and
you still had a lot of money right well
it was all collapsed in a class with the
dot-com bubble I was down to sit I was
down to six figures from seven net worth
so I was going out with wild man and my
gangster friends on the weekends and
still clicked up there so I was wild
when I got arrested and if I'd have got
releasing that first year I would have
gone back to the lifestyle but in the
second year when the prosecutor said I
was facing a maximum 200 year sentence
and that pushed me to the point of
suicidal insanity I thought to myself
all right they filed serious drug
offender status on me which carries 25
to life I've got 20 plus charges each
which carry 10 plus year sentences stack
top makes 200 mr. prosecutor made it
clear if I went to trial and lost I
would get 200 for that alone as well so
I'm thinking do I want to spend the rest
of my life in this kind of an
environment dead rats in the food
cockroaches crawling all over us at
night guards murdering mentally ill
prisoners just drug and gang infested
mayhem people's heads getting smashed in
every day it's just you know can I just
live like this for the rest of my life
no so I
decided to kill myself after a guard
that a security walk and before I was
going to slash my wrists I want to say
goodbye to my family and friends so I
get the pictures out my mom dad
girlfriend's sister when I started to
get really sad thinking my mom's gonna
get a call saying you know your son just
killed himself in the foreign jail and
to be honest I don't want anyone's pity
here I deserve to be in there by started
to cry at that point and the fart put my
mom through doubt just stopped me from
killing myself so that pressure on my
brain was working on crushing that
materialistic hedonistic narcissistic
person out of me and the turning point
round that time came a prisoner come
into my cell he's got a steel rod in his
leg the screws are loose he's in agony
he's got hepatitis C he's got syphilis
he's got stomach cancer and whenever he
goes on the toilet is in absolute agony
his stomach cancer is so advanced he's
gonna die in that jail within a couple
of years and I was thinking holy [ __ ] I
was feeling so sorry for myself I was
gonna slash my wrists and bleed out
listen to this guy's story there's
always somebody worse off and my heart
open to the pain and suffering of other
people I thought prisoners lock them up
throw away the key the serial killers
pedophiles rapists murderers because
that's all you see in the news how
extreme the crimes are on one side and
how easy is on the other they've all got
Playstations gourmet food luxuries and
that keeps the public hating on the
prison population but when I went to
court and the audience of all the other
prisoners in whenever first arrested
heard my charges and heard my bail was
750 thousand dollars bond they were all
gasping and they were gasping because
there were all low-level drug users and
people who were doing petty crimes of
finance drug addiction and the system
they are the fodder for the system
50,000
dollars a year of taxpayers money per
prisoner per arrest I saw black kids and
Mexican kids it was like a Rocha we'd
get like a two-year sentence because
they had prior convictions so Rocha we'd
two years taxpayer hundred thousand to
house that person it's just a
money-making industry
[Laughter]